retour effectivement sur la rivalité
entre dijon et besançon sur le plateau
de la voie est libre à une un débat on
va dire exacerbée par la fusion des
régions bourgogne franche comté nous
avons cinq invités autour de cette table
laurent grandguillaume député de
côte-d'or député ps eric alauzet left et
écologiste de france comptait donc du
doubs françois berthelon le président du
ceser le conseil économique et social
régional dominique roy président de la
cci du doubs et benoît vidaud de la
cgpme bourgogne franche comté et puis
dans cette deuxième partie on va se
consacrer à vos questions toutes les
questions vous nous avez envoyées depuis
le début de l'émission et depuis le
début de la semaine sur la page internet
de la voix est libre en bourgogne et en
franche comté puis aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux vous pouvez commander commenter
cette émission avec le modèle lvl dsc et
1 messieurs on commence avec cette
question de marilou si tout est à dijon
besançon deviendra-t-elle une ville
morte
question prix vers l instant ils sont
d'ailleurs tous n'est pas dijon donc
forcément aujourd'hui déjà il y à des
services on l'a dit rectorat on parlera
pas du tribunal merci donc voilà il y a
déjà des services à besançon comme à
dijon les hôpitaux les universités
d'ailleurs qu'ils travaillaient ensemble
donc on a des complémentarités qui
existe déjà c'est pas c'est pas la
guerre des étoiles a aujourd'hui donc
néanmoins encore efforts l'a évoqué en
première partie on a d'ailleurs beaucoup
de questions là je me sens marie-claude
sur les francs comtois savait qu'ils
seraient mangés par guillon en 15
secondes
il n'y aura pas de bonne fusion s'il
n'ya pas équilibre entre les deux c'est
à dire ce qu'il est donné à tous
aujourd'hui réellement jeu on essaye de
je pense que les politiques et l'état
essaye de le faire mais de toute façon
cela ne fonctionnera pas si besançon par
exemple devait être ce qu il en est pas
question
et pour nous au conseil économique on se
battra contre st ericsson
en tout cas cette réflexion et vous
devez en avoir de nombreuses elle
traduit parfaitement ce que je vous
expliquais tout à l'heure de l'émotion
qu'il ya sur le territoire de
demain soir la france la franche comté
doubs en grande partie justifiée après
cet épisode malheureux bien sûr canon
revient plus maintenant il faut trouver
les moyens de restituer de re re re
créer la confiance voilà c'est ça le
challenge qui est devant nous retrouvons
à partir de du travail qui avait été
fait consciencieusement par les uns et
par les autres sur les répartitions et
allons au bout de servat domingo tout
mettre sur la table pour tous mais on va
sur transparente pour cette action voilà
quand même être un minimum crédible et
parce que la question ça doit
normalement lister les parlementaires
sont quasiment tous en majorité les
maires sont pour la france rêvée
d'accord avec elle et qu'elle ose et la
communauté alliance voilà donc il y
apprend des maires sur 12 ans et mais je
ne vois pas de la france monte à
l'épargné donc je prenais pas des deux
régions en bourgogne aussi il ya des
députés républicains centristes ont donc
je disais seulement qu'entre dijon et
besançon
nous avons des convergences plus que des
divergences logiquement sur le fond
j'imagine donc normalement on devrait y
arriver
en tout cas j'espère attentif pour de
nouvelles questions alexandre on va où
je vais vous donner à part vous
inquiétez pas ça tombe bien c'est il ya
l'économie
notre nouvelle région ne possède aucune
métropole sur son territoire ne
serait-il pas judicieux de bénéficier de
la seule dérogation possible permettront
d'avoir deux capitales
et puis christophe renchérit at il une
volonté de l'état de créer des super
vilains cumulant les fonctions au
détriment des autres demis une métropole
nous la construire aujourd'hui la
métropole on va la construire je vais
commencer l'émission par sa wii en
disant il faut que dijon est un
rayonnement métropole et joueurs et
qu'elle tire la région je le pense et je
dis à nous de la construire et nous
d'être intelligents pour ne pas
s'opposer dans la construction d'une
grande métropole régionale sens
aujourd'hui je reviens sur la question
sans dédé retirer des habits et besançon
de ses forces et de ses qualités
économiques et de tout le rayonnement
qu'elle pourra apporter à cette
métropole rayonner il faut il on a pas
besoin de mettre sous l'éteignoir devant
sont absolument pas
une ville de débattre quantité d'aidé de
notre histoire parfois communes parfois
nos propres histoires dans ces villes et
c'est une chose d'identité de dijon et
de besançon et en même temps quelles
fonctionnalités on propose justement aux
citoyens et donc ça c'est de débats qui
sont différents je crois que parfois on
mélange les deux c'est à dire qu'en fait
on peut avoir le sentiment quand on a
besoin son nom que dijon demain capitale
régionale avec une métropole qui se
construisent ensemble dans un réseau
métropolitain qu'on puisse ce peut-être
être moins visibles peut-être donc il ya
la question d'identité mais il est
surtout quelle fonction on apporte
justement aux citoyens aux entreprises
aux territoires je le redis aux tpe et
aux pme aux pays qui créent des emplois
dans nos territoires et réalisé par être
confiance mais je vous allez réussir à
dépasser c'est une ville dynamique c'est
pas forcément une ville qui bénéficie
d'un statut et de direction c'est
important qu'elles ont bénéficié ou la
vie bande dessinée chaussures s'en vont
forcément il ya un impact sur le
commerce etc
mais c'est une ville qui se donne la
capacité d'agir dans le cadre du
développement économique est là je
rejoins complètement ce que ce que
disait benoît vidaud tout à l'heure en
identifiant nos forces et nos
complémentarités et bien c'est à nous
aussi de nous prendre en main et de
rendre nos villes dynamiques grenoble
grenoble n'est pas la capitale
ronald et pourtant c'est une ville d'un
dynamisme intérieur est d'ailleurs de
laquelle on peut se rapprocher de
fresques par les pôles d'excellence la
recherche des laboratoires donc alors
vous allez réussir à dépasser méfiance
mais on le trouve au quotidien en
travaillant dans les milieux économiques
ensemble et en créant ces partenariats
dont je vous ai parlé tout est une
question de gilbert critiqué françois
rebsamen qui défend les intérêts de sa
ville c'est hypocrite c'est le lot de
chaque merde on est bien sûr c'est
évident on essaye de les leur naturel
c'est la compétition bon on essaie de
contrecarrer sa part une action
volontariste tous ensemble de
coopération donc il faut la jouer
jusqu'au bout c'est dur de lutter contre
la compétition et puis les
des vertus aussi malgré tout mais voilà
cette fonction elle demeurera mais sur
cette affaire là je vais pas y revenir
encore une fois c'est est d' influence
voilà c'était bien au delà de la plus
ans
même si vous aussi vous êtes allé voir
françois hollande et je lui ai remis la
revue de presse jamais on a une revue de
presse estime portables sont attirés les
bananes - l'euro profite presque aux
mains de centimètres d'eau et je suis
désolé dans un ganglion à revenir à l'
influence avec ça veut dire que les
choix d'avion justement cette question
pourquoi dijon s'est rassemblé ses
forces politiques consulaires et la
population derrière ces grands projets
alors que besançon n'y arrive pas je
sais pas en tout cas sur ces risques par
exemple travaux est par exemple sur
cette affaire là ya vraiment une amie
unanimité en franche comté et tout le
monde s'est réuni tous les élus de tous
bords politiques tous les acteurs
économiques se sont réunis pour dire
stop
voilà ce qui s'était passé maintenant on
est en crise on purge le dossier on va
repartir sur des bases tous ensemble
volontaires pour réussi à non je pense
qu'il ya des alliances en franche-comté
autour des projets diverses et variées
il ya des années il ya des alliances qui
se font assez régulièrement je pense
aussi aussi fortement qu ici en bretagne
où l'arrivée est manque de cohésion de
l'eau moi je suis désolé je suis en tant
que président de cette région au niveau
du conseil économique je suis aussi
souvent à besançon moi j'entends des
ions les bisontins et et des franc
comtois qui sont en cohésion et est en
cohérence et il ya des gens qui suivent
leur mère qui suivent leurs élus de la
même façon vous n'entendez pas ses
inquiétudes
sincèrement de la part des citoyens
je trouve qu'il ya une cohésion qui est
franchement importante
alors est-ce que c'est contre quelque
chose ben moi je pense que c'est pas
seulement alors il ya eu effectivement
des points qui le point précis je vais
pas recommencer dessus parce que j'aime
en mai bien il ya aussi véritablement je
pense une approche ou mots et cette
approche la ressent quand même très
fortement en franche comté et entre
autres à besançon quand je me trouve et
souvent moi je arrêtons de dire que les
bisontins pont si on parle surtout des
bisontins aujourd'hui
arrêtons de dire que les bisontins sont
morcelées son c'est pas vrai il ya une
entité bisontine et là j'en fais j'en
suis véritablement témoin il ya
véritablement une volonté des bisontins
de fer et d'avancer dagnon daniel vous
demande
les sièges régionaux des entreprises
privées ou non partent vers dijon une
tendance qui semble automatique voire
naturel pourquoi quels sont les critères
objectifs qui motive ces choix
entreprises privées c'est le choix d'un
patron privé pour la valeur des produits
mis d'accord dès des banques et mis le
public ça ça nous échappe le privé c'est
un patron d'entreprise qui décideraient
de s'installer plus tôt à besançon qu'à
dijon était son choix s'il trouve plus
d'attractivité sur une ville ou sur une
autre se disait que c'est parce qu'un
groupe
aujourd'hui je serais acteurs
industriels dans la soute est sous
traitance de la micromécanique j'irais
plutôt m'installer du côté de besançon
si aujourd'hui je travaille autour de
l'agroalimentaire avec un bassin de
population une étude de marché qui est
meilleur au tour de dijon belge venir
ici c'est pas systématique je pense que
le bon sens dans l'entreprise ça fait
longtemps qu'on a dépassé les clivages
politiques
ça fait longtemps qu'on va là où il ya
du business c'est précis on prend la
comprend la nouvelle publiée par la une
a été classée première ville de france
pour entreprendre dans sa catégorie de
salariés d'airbus sur l'autel et je
sourire ce sujet des as ou d'accord avec
moi s'il n'y avait pas eu la fusion
peut-être que le mouvement sera accéléré
encore un peu plus et la fusion elle
permet tout son sens en tout cas sur la
partie sur laquelle nous avons la main
je parle pas des entreprises à cet
instant précis mais les administrations
rodez s'atténue de l'état d'auvours nous
permet de comprendre qu'au-delà de
contenir une évolution est naturel qui
peut-être aurait plus encore desservies
besançon donc il faut aussi mesurer un
peu les chevaux d'âge
je partage complètement c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'étais plus contre la
faim dans la pâte se plaint
on parle d'un point en particulier sur
lequel on ne jamais revenir mais si vous
avez raté le début de l'émission la
première partie d'une série de
l'implantation a dit le commerce pour
jour le débat le montre on est là en
train de dire qu'il y à une concurrence
qui doit être une saine concurrence
parce que facteur d'émulation et
développement de lunel au de nourrir sa
forme est justement un peu sur ce qui
peut se dire ici ou là ça et c'était
assez violent parfois dans les dents les
propos qu'on a pu voir les soul est donc
un coup de poignard dans le dos une
intrigue lamentable mais aussi à
besançon comme à dijon nous avons des
atouts qui sont liées à l'histoire
industrielle des vides à l'histoire
économique
regardez besançon a connu aussi des
filles dans l'histoire avec l'ip avec la
rodia avec bien d'autres grandes
industries et et a su se relever et en
fait à des atouts comme dijon et je
pense qu'on est complémentaire du point
de vue économique comme imprimer la
libano vidéo et donc il faut aller
ensemble pour faire ensemble des choses
des projets et je pense c'est comme ça
qu'on arrivera à a rassemblé sur les
projets c'est ce qui nous est commun
avec la dimension économique de cette
région fera aussi tourner vers sa
capacité à aller chercher des marchés
qui sont limitrophes
on parle de la suisse s'est passé
aujourd'hui
besançon sera tourné ça sera notre
ambassadeur pour aller chercher des
marchés vers la suisse et vers l'europe
limitrophes
le mâconnais ira plutôt vers lyon et
nous trouvons des synergies aussi
naturellement vers lyon le sénonais ça
sera plutôt vers l'île de france
donc tous seraient schalke c'est déjà le
cas mais on va bénéficier tout ça avec
cette nouvelle grande région il faut
construire des pôles de compétences en
fonction des arguments qu'ont les
différents territoires
une chance considérable dans la
bourgogne dans cette fusion alors je
lâche de l'ide au niveau de la bourgogne
c'est précisément cette proximité et ce
travail qui existe déjà entre la
franche-comté qui existait entre la
franche-comté et la suisse et je dirais
l axe rhénans en même temps beaucoup
plus largement et la bourgogne a tout à
y gagner
alors là c'est absolument évident de
même que nous avons la possibilité nous
d'offrir quand même à mon avis
de la franche-comté l'ouverture sur le
harry le nord rhône alpes rhône alpes
auvergne maintenant et sur le lest ile
de france on a véritablement un des
potentialités fantastique à développer
pour conclure en 30 secondes messieurs
donc ils vous ont rassuré les débats
étaient absolument nécessaires et utiles
il y aura traversé une crise il faut
purger les crises et crie ça veut dire
aussi opportunité pour rebondir et pour
aller au delà voilà donc moi ce que je
vous dit en conclusion c'est parions sur
la force de deux anciennes régions pour
n'en faire qu'une
mais qui reposera sur un axe fort qui
sera dijon besançon et je pense à l'air
urbaine aussi au nord de la
franche-comté et puis surtout pour les
dossiers à venir faisant de confiance
mettons tous les dossiers sur la table
on les voit de façon globale et on
traite on renforce nos pôles de
compétences wallabies en est on est on
tient et on sait la parole quand ces
derniers sont en mesure ont confiance
aux acteurs économiques à la société
civile est souvent marie-guite dufay
nous dit quand elle devait assister à
nos séances
la société civile est bien en avance sur
la société politique personnages et
l'avenir ce sera un mot de la fin merci
vous pouvez tous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en mer si jérémy alors c'est
que vous pouvez voir ou revoir à cette
édition sur nos sites internet très bon
week-end à tous